[Musique]
on a beau dire les légumes et les fruits
du jardin sont quand même meilleur que
ceux achetés dans le commerce n'est ce
pas ma soeur ça goûte le ferai cette
année les haricots verts a été bon pour
la récolte le jardinier les avait mis à
trois fois à chaque récolte on a eu au
moins trois quatre fois pour les 70 à 80
personnes
le péché aussi comme vous voyez ça il y
en a beaucoup
les jonctions peut-être pas tellement
tellement sucré mais elles sont bonnes
et savoureux savoureuse et bien
parisienne car ce potager verger nourith
en partie les prêtres de la maison marie
thérèse a une portée de mousquets de
denfert rochereau
ce pari des villages ne se laisse pas
facilement découvrir
on en doute le charme discret est encore
à sharon ou bien à passy dans cette
charmante rue berton ou au pied de la
maison de balzac subsiste l'ancien
bornes entre auteuil et pas si il a plus
vieilles maisons de paris celle du 3 rue
volta c'est possible mais la plus belle
est sans doute à l'angle de la rue
françois miron et de la rue cloche pers
pour le parisien la montée de la rue
saint-blaise jusqu'à saint germain de
charonne est une des promenades
dominicales les plus agréables qui soit
en août bien entendu et non loin voici
sans doute la voie la plus étroite de
paris 84 cm de large
le passage de la douille arrêtons nous
un instant devant la maison la plus
exigeante de la capitale 39 rue du
château d'eau un étage 1 m 31 de façade
ancien sentent des mus'arts de la rue
des cascades est ainsi nommé parce que
le regard saint-martin construite en 16
133 et reconstruite en 1722 recueillait
les autres belles lui jusqu'en 1899
quittant la prison de la roquette
les condamnés à mort faisait ces
quelques pas qui les menait à la
guillotine ils la découvrent est ici
dressé sur cinq pavé large qui existe
toujours rue de la croix foba sur ce
coup là le s'endort cynique avait tenté
d'assassiner napoléon iii en 1858 de
l'anarchiste henry et de bien d'autres
assassins célèbre le premier modèle de
la guillotine avait été essayé ici en
1792 sur des moutons décapité près de ce
puits cours d'euros mais comment le
sait-on
voilà c'est ici
lors des travaux
pour l'ouverture de ce peuple en 68 nous
avons découvert un puits et dans ce
puits
nous avons trouvé des quantités dose de
moutons à notre grande surprise il n'y
avait pas de crâne il est fort possible
que les carcasses se démonte ont été
transportés après les essais dans ce
puits le plus curieux cimetière de paris
est sans doute 44 rue de flandre
c'est là qu'à partir de 1790 contre une
redevance de santé qu on pouvait se
faire enterrer les juifs de paris à
condition que leur interne ans ce fils
de nuit sans scandale ni appareil en la
matière a coutume et il fallut attendre
napoléon pour que des cimetières
parisiens soit ouvert aux juifs le seul
cimetière paroissial qui est continuer à
subsister à côté de son église est avec
celui du calvaire à montmartre le
cimetière de sharon dans son enclos une
curieuse statut de bergues dit le père
magloire qui se prétendait le secrétaire
de robespierre et ne le fut jamais rue
de belleville un vestige unique le
regard de la lanterne tête de l'aqueduc
qui alimentait au xvème siècle
six des onze puis parisien descendons
dans la plaine ou en 1826 messieurs
verreault et d'audace charcutier de
l'heure et à ouvrir une galerie
marchande qui aux nouveautés fut éclairé
au gaz
c'était la première
ce lieu devient vite à la mode rachel
loue un appartement au dessus de la
galerie où alfred de musset 20 dîner
balsa qui passaient souvent attirés par
l'opulente poitrine de madame verreault
avec ses cuivres c'est marc ses
boutiques de collectionneurs la galerie
a gardé le charme discret de la
bourgeoisie louis-philippe hard
mais on peut en dire autant de la
galerie vivienne sa contemporaine qui
commet sur une rotonde orné de nymphes
et de ds en 1832 l'abbé gazzara y
présentait son invention le cosmo rama
sorte de lanterne magique où l'on voyait
des paysages derrière des miroir
grossissant donnant l'impression du
relief
[Musique]
en face de la galerie ruera divine les
étonnants escaliers de la maison qui
abritait un tripot pendant la révolution
ils sont construit de telle sorte que
celui qui descend ne doit pas celui qui
monte et inversement
jadis une cloison isoler chacun de ces
deux escaliers parallèle dont il
n'existe que deux autres exemples en
france et voilà
ni vu ni connu le vendredi 13 juillet
1607 henri iv posait la première pierre
de l'hôpital saint louis
heureusement conservé jusqu'à nos jours
il constitue le plus bel ensemble
architectural du début du règne de louis
xiii
bien qu'il commence selon le mot de
jacques hillairet à être étouffée par de
nombreux agrandissement moderne
en cherchant bien on y découvre le buste
du vert galant et en cherchant encore
mieux un petit bâtiment que l'histoire
rappelle le pavillon de chasse d'henri
iv mais qui ressemble plutôt à une folie
ainsi nommé ton jadis les abris discret
des amoureux fortunés
découvrons enfin un lieu plus austère
l'admirable cloître de l'abbaye de port
royal construit en 1627 par la mère
angélique alors abaisse de port royal
des champs qui fut abandonnée par l as
et religieuses en raison de l'humidité
qui régnait dans la vallée de chevreuse
trois siècles après il sert de lieu de
promenade aux futures mamans des
maternités baudelocque et de port royal
[Musique]